نبقى مع كليان مبابي واشرف حكيمي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي اعادت نشره مقطع مصور
للاعبين في يناير من العام الجاري اثناء
زياره فريق باريس سان جيرمان للعاصمه
القطريه حينها زار اللاعبان ملعب المدينه
التعليميه بقيق قال حينها ان الملعب
سيستضيف مباراه فرنسا وتونس بدوري
المجموعات ولاحقا ستلتقي فرنسا والمغرب
وان فرنسا ستفوز ومنذ انتقال حكيمي الى
باريس سان جيرمان قبل موسمين توطدت
العلاقه مع بابي فعاده ما يظهر اللاعبان
معا في التدريبات وايضا مرات كثيره خارج
الملعب غدا سيكون اللاعبان متنافسين على
ارض الملعب عندما يلتقي منتخبات المغرب
وفرنسا في نصف نهائي مونديال قطر نشير
اخيرا الى ان تتوقع بابي بشان مواجهه
فرنسا وتونس لم يكن صحيحا لان تونس فازت
حينها فهل سي متوقعه هذه المره ام سيخب
مجددا غدا سنعرف النتيجه
التعليميه الذي يتسع ل 40 الف مشجع فرنسا
وتونس ستلعبان هنا سنفوز ثم سنلتقي مع
المغرب
وسيكون هدفي تدمير صديقي اشرف ساحطم
الامر سيكسر قلبه ولكن هذه الكره يجب ان
يدمره
وسيكون احد منتخبين الارجنتين او كرواتيا
نبدا مع كرواتيا وصيفه النسخه السابقه هذا
المنتخب اعتاد على لاعب اشواط اضافيه في
المراحل الاقصائيه وصولا الى النهائي كما
حدث في النسخه الاخيره وهو ما تكرر في هذه
البطوله امام كل من اليابان والبرازيل طول
مدى المباريات جعل المحللين يتساءلون عما
اذا كانت خبره المباريات الطويله ستساعد
كرواتيا امس ستؤدي لارهاق لاعبيها
وستعتمد كرواتيا بشكل كبير على قائدها
لوكا مودريتش القادر على الاحتفاظ بالكره
وصنع الهجمات الخطيره باعتباره العقل
المدبر من الناحيه الهجوميه كرواتيا على
الجانب الاخر
تبين او يبين ظهور ليونيل ميسي كصانع
للالعاب
ماذا نجعته خاصه خلال تمريرته التي جاء
منها هدف الارجنتين الوحيد امامه هولندا
في المباراه الماضيه
نقطه النقص الوحيده في منتخب التانجو ربما
هي في عدم وجود مهاجم صريح من الطراز
العالمي على خلاف كرواتيا واذا كانت الفرص
متقاربه على الورق تتفوق الارجنتين بشكل
واضح فهي ااا في المدرجات حيث يتوقع ان
يساندها على الاقل اربعين الف ارجنتينيه
اضافه لمحبي هذا المنتخب من مختلف الدول
العالم